today we're going to be speaking with
former republican congressman from
illinois joe walsh former presidential
candidate host of the new podcast white
flag with joe walsh really appreciate
your time
hey david i've been a fan of yours it's
good to be on with you man thank you so
okay i mean so to start to give the
audience some sense i mean in in the tea
party era you were not just a republican
you were sort of like a leading voice in
the tea party movement
strong opponent
of barack obama um and then at some
point during the trump era things things
started to change for you yeah
that's a that's a gentle way of putting
it david yeah you're right look i i was
a tea party guy a big tea party leader
you would have called me a crazy tea
partier back in the day yes and you and
i could have had some interesting
debates and fights about the tea party
but generally it was about issues
and then trump came along and now the
republican party the party i belong to
my whole life
is basically an
anti-democratic cult
and i didn't want to belong to a cult it
doesn't matter where you stand on the
issues uh it's always been the issues
that drove me i don't recognize this
party anymore yeah and what's
interesting about that is when i chart
the path to donald trump of the
republican party
the tea party in my mind was a big piece
of that in other words
you you now say well the tea party made
sense to me but trump doesn't but if we
go back to the civil rights era and then
reagan gingrich in 94 bush
the way i've seen it is all of this has
been a move by the republican party away
from substance and towards cultural
issues and being
anti-democratic and it's interesting
that i mean do you agree that the tea
party in a way set the stage for trump
absolutely oh you do
yeah no you're spot on and in fact
i've publicly apologized for helping
bring you and i in the whole country
trump what i did helped bring trump um i
look at it like this david the the the
republican party base is mostly
middle-aged older white people and for
years and years the party establishment
ignored them and their concerns and then
tea party people like me came along and
inflamed them and riled them up
and then by the time trump came along in
16
they were primed baby to be captivated
by a cult so to be captivated by a
demagogue so i led to trump i think the
republican party establishment did as
well
when did you
okay so when when trump started to run
uh what what was your initial thought
and how did that evolve over time
david i screwed up i didn't pay enough
attention to him when trump started
running in 15 and 16 i was on the radio
you know right-wing talk radio 200
stations around the country but i never
paid enough attention to him i didn't
take him seriously i voted for him in 16
because he wasn't hillary i figured he's
just a goof and maybe he'll play golf
for four years and nothing will happen i
[ __ ] excuse me i messed up david
i messed up
once he got elected i started to pay
attention to him and i realized every
time he opened his mouth he told a lie i
couldn't live with that and then i began
to see and really see all the uglier
things he did
my final straw david was helsinki in the
summer of 2018 when he stood on that
stage and said i'm with putin and not
the americans that was the greatest act
of disloyalty i've ever heard i went on
the radio that night and said i'm going
to do everything i can to make sure he's
not reelected i began to lose then my
radio show and everything shortly
thereafter so here's one of the things
i'm interested in because we earlier
this week we were reading about
republicans holding closed-door meetings
to try to figure out how can we
get trump's grip on the party loosened
and all of these things i've seen no
evidence that those folks
are actually against the
authoritarianism of trump it seems they
just don't like trump at the head but
that they're sort of okay with the
authoritarianism that has been ushered
in by trump where where are you on that
issue like is the problem just trump or
is it the trumpism that i mean like
desantis to me seems like it's the same
sort of mold for example
uh david i
you and i agree man i totally agree look
it uh trump has metastasized
he unleashed it it is now trumpism if
trump went away tomorrow it'll be a
desantis or somebody like that who will
it
it's a party now that has embraced
authoritarianism
that is this republican party i don't
want to be a part of that so anybody who
stands against that
no longer has a place in this party
so like when you i mean in figuring out
your politics now
when you look at joe biden for example
like just to pick taxes i don't know
depict something right joe biden wants
the top tax rate to go up a couple
points and there are some on the right
who want like a 25 top tax rate or
whatever
when you see
the trump and biden differences on taxes
like on that policy issue where would
you like to see the top tax rate
well i probably don't support either one
you know trump's tax reform
piece legislation that he passed right
away i thought was a lousy piece of
legislation because it did lower taxes
for wealthier americans uh david i
generally support a notion of a flat tax
simplifying the tax oh yes simplifying
the tax code so that wealthier americans
who got all the accountants and the
lawyers i think most studies i've read
if you simplify the code wealthy people
actually pay more i'd prefer a route
like that that i don't think buy nor
trump support well i think so okay if
you figure out the effective tax that's
being paid by the very rich and then you
set the flat tax above that and you say
not only is this the flat tax it's also
the minimum tax so that you can't
loophole and deduct your way out of it
you could have a situation where the
very rich do pay more i think the
problem people would have then is
somebody making 40 000 a year is paying
the same rate would you to dig a little
deeper on this
have some threshold below which you pay
no federal tax or how do you deal with
the regressive nature of it
i think there's always got to be some
threshold where people
uh
at a certain level don't pay taxes i i
do believe but i do believe generally
david and you and i might disagree on
this the notion of progressivity in a
tax rate i generally oppose really i
generally yeah i generally believe just
a flat rate
uh and and the more money you make
you're going to pay more because you're
making more money but i don't believe
you should have a higher rate but david
what's fascinating to me is
i can't remember having this discussion
in the last five years or all like like
actually talking about a substantive
policy issue the republican party
doesn't talk about stuff like this
anymore
so to that end
why would they start going back to
issues if it's not clear they need to to
win races right and and you know you
look at like the glenn yunken victory in
virginia
the only thing approximating quote
policy was that he would stop the
teaching of critical race theory which
was not being taught so if they can win
on that stuff what's the incentive to
get back to policy
they have none right uh david which is
why i believe
and i get into this debate with some of
my fellow former republicans who think
this party can be saved i don't think it
can now but i also believe david that i
i do believe the republican party is a
dying national party which might sound
oxymoronic right now because they'll
probably take back the house next year
yeah but it's becoming a strong rural
regional party i think it stays as a
national party are dying
is there a national republican right now
that you say that this is someone kind
of like in my this is someone who thinks
sort of like me like maybe mitt romney
or
is there anybody right now that you see
and you say that's who i would like to
see the future of the party be
well you know it's odd david i i'm not
i'm not a moderate and no one would ever
call me a moderate but generally the
only national
non-trumpy republicans are moderates
like a romney
but there's no way on god's green earth
mitt romney or anybody like that could
get a nomination in this in this party
yes so i guess then the question becomes
what happens in in 2024 and i think
there's two questions if the question is
who is the best shot of winning i don't
think it's anybody you would actually
like to see representing the party if
the question is what's what would be
best for the party and the country i
think you're right there doesn't really
seem to be an interest in that type of
republican right now among the
republican voters
look david never trump to me and i'm a
never trumper never trump to me means
never him and never anybody any
republican who supported him after four
years of his presidency so i can never
support any republican who voted for
trump in 24 that's desantis that's pence
that's cruz any of them
now not every never trumper is where i
am but generally look david i think if
trump runs in 24 the nomination is his
nobody challenges him if he doesn't run
you've got to be the most trumpiest
person you can be to win that nomination
at this point on social issues for a for
a while
the republic the most conservative
elements of the republican party
including the tea party
made a big deal out of we're against gay
marriage for example
uh abortion played a big role you know a
lot of these kind of social issues to
some degree some of these issues are
settled gay marriage for example is
settled and you just don't hear much
more about it from from republicans
there's renewed interest on abortion now
because of what's going on for for the
supreme court
where are you on those social issues and
do you think it's to the advantage of
republicans to run on them or it's
better to not even talk about those
issues
it's probably an advantage because
that's where their base is i'd quibble
with you on one thing david yeah when it
comes to the tea party and the base
of the republican party i've always
thought there were two strands to the
tea party one was the anti-debt anti you
know fiscal keep your fiscal house in
order strand but there was an uglier
social issue
nationalist populist bigoted strand as
well um and the republicans when it
comes to issues right now that's the
only game they play is this culture war
stuff um and that's all they're going to
talk about and run on um i've over the
years if i've evolved or changed at all
david i've probably become more proudly
woke i'm generally more libertarian in
my leanings i always have been more live
and let live
but that's not where the republican base
is
they're socially very conservative yeah
and along those lines
what is your assessment of the so you've
got the voters who when they're surveyed
republican voters
around 55 percent right now want trump
to run again which is still more than
half but it's lower than it was a year
ago
some similar number believes that trump
was actually the winner in november of
2020 and one of the things we've talked
about is like do they really believe
this stuff or do they see it as what you
have to say to be part of the club on
the elected officials like the senators
and the members of the house
do you think they believe the big lie
stuff or that they similarly realize
they have to say it to stay on trump's
team
hey david i talk to hundreds sometimes
thousands of republican voters every day
the vast majority of them believe this
stuff okay when it comes to my former
colleagues in congress
most don't oh interesting you've got a
small group of the crazies jim jordan
marjorie taylor green and paul gosars
they believe this stuff but the biggest
most dangerous piece of the republican
party elected official base is all of
those my former colleagues who know it's
all bs
but they keep their mouths shut that's
the biggest part of the elected
officials do you think that if it looks
like trump's gone in 24 they immediately
abandoned even the the premise that they
might believe this stuff is it just for
self-preservation or they're to keep
going no because it's always been about
the base these guys privately david have
never been afraid of trump right when i
primary trump they would call me
privately and say i love what you're
saying about them they're they they knew
that trump they know that trump has a
lot lock on the base
so they've always been afraid of the
voters they don't want to lose those
voters so again if trump's gone tomorrow
desantis or somebody is going to get
them and these republicans are generally
cowards they sold their soul
and it will stay that way beyond trump
there's this uh phenomena we've been
seeing along these lines of saying one
thing and believing another
where in the last i'd say year and a
half or you know we could even say like
when trump was banned from twitter it
became visible there's the stated
principle from some of these folks like
for example
businesses basically should be as
unregulated as possible let them do what
they want as long as it's not illegal
and once the real world becomes
inconvenient to the principal they say
oh we've got to regulate twitter all of
it we need government to tell twitter
exactly who they have we need to force
twitter to allow these views etc
how concerned are you about the ease
with which the principles are abandoned
when the outcome is inconvenient
uh david extremely and it's it's it's
been the most disappointing aspect of
the this republican party not just the
abandonment of principles but the
embrace of authoritarianism of fascism
uh
to to actually use the power of
government
to
shut down voices that you don't agree
with look at that crap that desantis is
doing down in florida yeah uh uh uh
get rid of anything taught about race in
schools that makes people uncomfortable
having the government do that and we're
seeing some of the same republicans in
other states who want to shut down
speech about uh
lgbtq issues that make them
uncomfortable
this this embrace of i want a dictator
to shut up people who i disagree with
that's this party now i find it
frightening if you ran again would you
run independent i mean it seems like
there's basically no home in the
republican party it doesn't sound like
you really have an interest in being a
democrat
here hey david here's the truth i
realized two three years ago i have no
home in this party adam kinzinger and i
are really good friends adam kinzinger
knows privately he has no home in this
party um
what do i do i i could become a democrat
but between you and i
i don't know that the democrats would
want someone like me i don't know that i
would fit there i think what's going to
happen is temporarily people like me are
going to be political independents i do
believe david that within eight years
there's going to be a new major
political party occupying the middle
yeah i mean because when you look at
some of your positions and if these are
out of date then you know we can correct
them but a lot of these things
you're against the death penalty as far
as i know
you're for the legalization of marijuana
you've come around on the science on
climate change yes um on on immigration
i i guess where are you on immigration
at this point
i've i've always
been supportive of the party and opposed
in that i'm a huge hawk when it comes to
illegal immigration but i'm a huge
embracer of expanding
legal immigrants coming in i don't know
where that puts me what and on daca the
people that were brought here as minors
we got to find a permanent solution
right yeah i mean it's like it it seems
my audience might go crazy but in in
talking to you it sort of sounds like
there's not that much difference between
you and a moderate centrist democrat at
this point well which that's interesting
david and today's republican party is
very anti-legal immigration as well yeah
so i don't fit there i'm very pro-gun i
am pro-life right uh i'm i'm very i can
fiscally i'm very conservative and
almost libertarian on social safety net
i mean i know in the past you you were
very you at one point i think you said
there's no
there's no nothing in the constitution
that points to having any kind of social
safety nets have you moderated at all on
that
well i have not yeah no
that's still true but i still
acknowledge that government needs to
play a role to help those who can't help
themselves and i would argue over the
years we've expanded that social safety
net to the point where we're not helping
the people who really need help so
you're not against having it but you
want it to function meet its goals in a
better way i guess yeah i want it to be
more limited to like like a free college
for everybody no free college for people
who absolutely can't afford it sure
every every government program i want
very targeted we tend to expand these
programs to include everybody got it got
it well listen it's gonna be very
interesting in nine months to see
whether your
version
of republicanism
is at all welcomed by voters and of
course can't what candidates there are
to choose from will be a big part of
that but i'm i'm as interested as you
are in seeing what happens
i think uh no i agree david i don't
think there's room in the republican
party for people like me anymore i think
the democrats have a great opportunity
there's a political realignment going on
the party can grow
if they take people from the center
right all the way to progressives
because the republican party is
shrinking right right uh former
republican congressman joe walsh thank
you so much for your time i really
appreciate it hey david it's been an
honor thank you sir